we have some brand new leaks for
hogwarts legacy to discuss today but
before you get your hopes up too much i
think it's pretty likely these leaks
are fake and i'll explain why
that being said once we actually start
to take a look at what's in the leaks
i do think some of them could actually
happen and we're starting
right now people of the internet's
retrorecontour here if we're meeting for
the first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
which i'm happy to announce guys monday
january 4th
the twitch streams are coming back make
sure you follow twitch.tv
retrorecontour we're going to be
streaming harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone
the pc version so as fans of hogwarts
legacy you guys know we've been looking
for
any new bits of information about the
game since things have been pretty much
dead
in terms of new things since the trailer
now there was a recent
leak posted over on the harry potter
games subreddit that honestly
i wouldn't even normally bring this up
because of how unlikely i think it is to
be legitimate it's one of those classic
my brother's uncle's wife's cousin works
at wb and heard this
but i thought you know what let's just
take a look at what they're saying and
see if these supposed leaks are things
we could
actually see happening now if you're new
to the channel and want to keep up with
all the latest hogwarts legacy news
when we have it that is as well as
theories and speculation then be sure to
subscribe to the channel and don't
forget to ring the notification bell so
you won't miss any new
videos right now as far as this leak
goes i'll include a link to it in the
description below so you guys can go and
read it all for yourselves
if you want but i'm going to break it
down right here for you the title of the
post which is actually from a specific
subreddit called
gaming leaks and rumors which was in
cross posted over
on the harry potter game subreddit but
the title is hogwarts legacy is like
bully with magic now a lot of you out
there probably remember bully from
rockstar
and a lot of folks talking about
hogwarts legacy have brought up
bully as a game that it could possibly
draw some inspiration from
now as far as what the leak actually
says let's just go through these
one by one and we'll talk about what we
think of each one here so
first point here fall 2021 which okay
nothing too crazy here could definitely
see that the next one full
character customization now the early
leaks that were
pretty heavily legitimate leaks i think
it's just about confirmed they were
legitimate at this point
but those early leaks actually showed a
character creator i'll throw up a
screenshot of it here and we also know
avalanche is really playing up this idea
of character choice and you being able
to
choose your path in the game so i don't
think this is a shock at all full
character customization like what does
that even mean full character
customization
of course you're gonna be able to create
your own character we already know that
they've said that now here's where it
starts to get a little bit juicy true
next generation destruction technology
they have a lore reason with magic for
how areas you destroyed are repaired
when you next
go to these areas true next generation
destruction technology like what
again what does that really mean i mean
i think they could be pulling this
from the fact that in the trailer we
sort of see this area i'll pull it up
right here of this bridge kind of
reconstructing
so that could be of an extension
possibly of what they're talking about
there
now a lot of us have talked about the
idea of exploring secret passages and
things like that in the castle so i
think this would be great if it makes it
in being able to destroy
parts of a room that maybe unlocks
something or
we've seen quite a few areas that look
like a cave in the trailer so if there's
a lot of destruction involved as spells
are being cast and flying around then i
think that would really help with the
immersion in the game and again this
seems
fairly plausible to me next point tons
of
classes with mini-games which improve
your skills stats wizarding level
etc okay classes with minigames let's
start there first because we've seen
this
in pretty much all the harry potter
games so we know there's going to be
classes we know there will
likely be some form of minigame there's
got to be something you do
in those classes right that are going to
improve your stats
your level all that stuff so again i
don't think anything there is is too
outlandish the part that is going to
raise some eyebrows though is where it
says
tons of classes so i mean i wouldn't
even describe
every class at hogwarts as being tons of
classes so maybe it just means that
you're going to be able to go to
quite a few multiple sessions i could
see that
next point here full house system
depending on how you play your house
will be awarded
stricken of points the end of the game
will have a house winner seen which is
dependent on your house score
now we've talked a lot about this in our
predictions and things we expect to see
i think it would be really strange if
they did not have something like this
in the game the question for me though
is how do you structure it in a way that
feels authentic you don't want it to
feel like your house is
always guaranteed to win i think i think
you should actually be able to lose if
they put something like that in
next point young dumbledore and this one
is what could ultimately prove or
disprove the legitimacy of these leaks
right here
there's some new information that's been
brought to my attention from an official
hogwarts legacy source that could
possibly debunk
the idea of young dumbledore being in
the game that's
going to be touched on in a separate
video because even though it does come
from an official source it's still
kind of unclear to me if it actually
confirms there is no
young dumbledore or not but we are going
to be talking about that later as far as
the trailer goes we know it says late
1800s so depending on how late we're
talking dumbledore could in fact be in
it and be at hogwarts
next point social systems you can
interact with npcs and similar to
rockstar bully
compliment taunt them at your own
discretion taunt someone too much and
they will report you to a teacher
so get out of there or suffer losing
house points
this was kind of cool it's i guess
they're starting to branch out a little
bit more and taking a little bit of a
risk here
i don't know that there's anything too
outlandish of course you're gonna be
able to interact with npcs that would
just be quite bizarre if you couldn't in
an open world action rpg
and bully is one of those games that not
only gets brought up in this leaks but
gets brought up in
other conversations about hogwarts
legacy i think it only makes sense that
they look
to bully for some guidance on this game
because the fact that it was set in a
school and it was open world
of course it's a much older game that
was limited by the technology they had
at the time we certainly have a lot more
technology at our disposal now so they
can do a lot more
i would say but it wouldn't surprise me
at all if we see elements that are
heavily inspired by bully in hogwarts
legacy
this idea of taunting someone too much
and they will report you to a teacher
though that that kind of cracks me up i
hope we have peeves in this game we know
the movies cut him out the he was in the
first video game and then they
he just never appeared again so if
you've got taunting in this game then we
absolutely
peeves needs to be there come on the
next piece they discuss here story is
very dark
comparable to the later hp movies
although it starts off somewhat colorful
and happy akin to sorcerer's stone and
chamber of secrets before going full-on
deathly hallows by the climax of the
narrative
yeah again just like not a lot of meat
here i i think this is
comparing it to the later hp movies
that's not really going out on a limb
you know
i think that makes a lot of sense it's a
game being made
set in this world where we know from
those early leaks we saw blood
in the trailer when they were fighting
against goblins i mean there was an axe
that
connected with a goblin so i do think
this is going to be a little bit more
mature i still think they're going to
shoot for a teen rating though i know a
lot of people are
hoping they just go all out for that m
and don't even care but
i definitely think they're still going
to try and stay within the team but that
being said
they can still make a very mature story
next one will
interweave with fantastic beasts
3 somehow now this one is one that feels
a little bit
off the wall for me now i had actually
tossed out the idea in one of my recent
videos and said
maybe the reason we're not seeing a lot
of marketing is because they're trying
to adjust
given the fact that fantastic beasts 3
has been delayed
now this game is set to come out 2021
the same time when fantastic beasts 3
was originally set to come out 2021. so
to me it makes a lot of sense and i
think it's probably very possible that
they had some sort of
cross-promotion that they were going to
do between the movie and the game
now that the movie isn't going to come
out that obviously goes out the window
but given the difference of time periods
here
i i don't know how they would pull this
off unless it's like some sort of piece
of lore or a relic that we're going to
find that will eventually surface in
fantastic beasts three
it could be something small like the
fact that we learn about bowtruckle
island through newt in the movies
or something way more significant next
one you can visit all the popular
locations from the books and movies even
completely new ones such as caves and
tombs buried beneath hogwarts this one
to me sounds like they're just taking
the official word of avalanche so far
and then slightly adding a new bit from
it i mean avalanche has already said we
know hogwarts is in we know hogsmeade is
in
we know the forbidden forest is in and
they've even teased completely new
locations so
we've seen caves and tombs in the
trailer that
again not a surprise at all but the fact
that they're saying here you can visit
all the popular locations from the books
and movies
to me that would be pretty fast i mean
in that point we're talking godric's
hollow we're talking grimmell place
we're talking ministry of magic we're
talking st
mungo's and personally i just don't
think they're going to fit
every single location in from the
original series i would be surprised
pleasantly surprised but i would be
surprised for sure
next one for me is by far the most
interesting one because it's it's really
unclear what
exactly they're talking about here but
it says will feature
a raid system from everything we've been
told about this game this game
is a single player game we don't really
have anything
at all so far that hints that it could
possibly be
a multiplayer game we know we're going
to have companions they've talked about
that
but those seem to be npc companions so
when i hear raid of course i'm thinking
like world of warcraft destiny those
types of raids here and
as anyone who has played those raids
know that it relies heavily on
multiplayer on co-op with your teammates
now personally i would love this but if
it does feature this this would have to
be something completely
separate from the main game and these
are usually high level
end game activities to me of all the
ones here that one sounds the most
implausible i would be
happy if they did it but it just doesn't
feel right for an action rpg with a
single player focus it would be the one
here that's kind of out of left field
for me
and then the very last one here you can
ride vehicles and animals tame
animals even we know that this has
already been confirmed that you contain
animals you can ride animals
i don't know what they mean by vehicles
maybe brooms maybe carriages we see in
the opening of the trailer you come in
on a carriage
we see the player with a broom and then
they add one more point that says
marketing should pick up
very soon if it really does plan to
release in fall 2021 i'd expect some
gameplay in the next few months
okay so i think it's important to
distinguish the difference between the
legitimacy of the leaks in terms of
are they actually coming from a valid
source versus are the points being made
in the leaks
actually possible on the first point
there i think it's highly unlikely
these are coming from a valid source i
mean at the start of the leak it says
exactly this i'll just quote it here
word for word for you quote
basically outside qa has started taking
place on hogwarts legacy
my cousin's friend who was an engineer
on their tools team has confirmed this
indirectly so i think this is someone
just messing around probably a kid
my cousin's friend who is an engineer on
their
tools team has confirmed this indirectly
anyone who's ever worked in journalism
or studied journalism would know
immediately that this is far
from confirmation so that's one side of
this leak here i don't think you should
take it as 100
fact but i do think it's kind of fun to
look at the points being made and see
how plausible they are and as i read
through them there
you guys i'm curious to see what you
think i don't think any of them are all
that outlandish with the exception of
the raid one
everything else to me sounds like it
makes perfect sense a lot of it has
actually been confirmed already
so until we get actual new concrete
information from wb from avalanche on
this
we're really just left for theories and
speculation right now so stay tuned for
our follow-up video this week we're
going to talk about that bit of
information i teased earlier about the
possibility
of young dumbledore being officially
confirmed
not to be in the game we'll talk about
that some later in the week
as always guys thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon